yeah piece of molded glass it's probably
a piece of tableware a candy dish sure
you found grandma's candy one of the
surprises that we encountered when we
started to analyze the artifacts that we
excavated back in the lab is that some
of the remains speak to a
high-visibility of women in the late
19th century cork town neighborhood
we've found combs for supporting the
popular women's hairstyles of the time
we found buttons from their dresses and
jackets and pins so questions as simple
as what were their bodily concerns at
the time what were the conventions of
appropriate dress and public display at
the time these are questions we can
answer about the women who lived in the
neighborhood that I never thought we'd
be able to access ever again we've
looked into their employment history
insofar as we could access it from the
census records and it really put a new
spin on what working-class meant for
this community some of the women were
piano teachers some were actresses some
were ticket takers in the theater some
were teachers and nurses really ran the
gamut of possibilities for women's
employment in the late 19th century
early 20th century
you